bonjour à toutes et à tous et bonjour à
notre invité mélanie et rtement bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes écologue
généraliste vous nous préciser ce que
cela signifie et vous êtes spécialiste
dans le domaine des milieux aquatiques
ça tombe bien puisque précisément
aujourd'hui nous fêtons les 50 ans donc
de la signature de la convention de
ramsar pour la conservation et
l'utilisation durable des zones humides
ramsar étant une ville iranienne de
l'iran vous nous en préciser la teneur
de cette convention et comment elles
s'appliquent en martinique mais
dites-nous d'abord mélanie rtement ce
qu'est un écologue ou une écologue on
imagine que c'est en rapport avec
l'écologie
mais personnellement je ne savais pas
qu'il y avait un métier qui se désignait
par par ce terme alors dites-nous en
quoi ça consiste en l'occurrence je suis
une éco log et c'est un métier qui a une
formation vraiment continue à
l'université alors écologue écossais
l'habitat et le métier des colloques en
fait s'intéresse à étudier ou à suivre
les interactions des écosystèmes à
nantes y est c'est à dire vraiment d'une
mare d'une plage entre d'autres
écosystèmes et aussi il s'intéresse à
étudier les pressions dit un tropiques
c'est à dire les pressions humaines qui
vont s'exercer sur ces écosystèmes la
différence entre un écologue par exemple
est un biologiste c'est que le
biologiste s'intéresse à un individu
tandis qu'annie colloque va s'intéresser
à un écosystème composé d'individus
animal végétal microbiologiques et c'est
alors on l'a dit vous êtes un
spécialiste dans ce domaine justement
des milieux aquatiques puisque vous
occuper et donc on va le dire quand même
hein c'est assez pointus dont vous êtes
habilité tout à fait légitimes à venir
nous parler de cette convention de
ramsar puisque vous avez une thèse de
doctorat en écologie et ingénierie
écologique est également un dea
recherche spécialité écosystèmes et
anthropisation c'est ce que vous venez
de nous expliquer entre autres a le cv
est très long donc voilà
mélanie rtement vous avez de vous
travaillez aussi avec une organisme
l'association peut-être je ne sais pas
vous nous préciser ce que c'est nature
et développement ici oui c'est un
cabinet que j'ai fondée il ya maintenant
presque cinq ans et qui en fait travail
auprès d'autres partenaires enfin ou
pour d'autres partenaires ou pour les
services de l'état les collectivités
locales
puisqu'en fait maintenant ça fait plus
de 11 années que je travaille dans la
caraïbe sur les écosystèmes donc de
zones humides mangrove milieux
aquatiques et j'ai pu travailler avant
au cnrs et puis dans des cabinets
d'études privé et puis il y à il ya
quatre cinq ans j'ai fondé en fait
nature et développement pour pouvoir
travailler sur ces milieux anna
comparant vous du travail et c'est pas
seulement pour comment dirais-je
dispenser des conseils vous n'êtes pas
une consultante en fait voilà c'est
aussi une femme de terrain j'ai envie de
dire de ce point de vue là voilà
complètement ya plusieurs casquettes en
fait à ce métier il ya des casquettes
d'accompagnement effectivement de
sensibilisation parfois mais c'est pas
du tout mon coeur de métier en revanche
d'enseignement notamment à l'université
ou bien informations au cnfpt et puis
effectivement beaucoup de terrain c'est
ça qui m'anime énormément c'est à dire
se rendre sur le terrain près leurs
enseignants racontez-nous ce que ce que
vous faites donc vous me disiez en off
un peu avant l'interview que par exemple
quand vous allez justement auprès de
rivière par exemple vous partez tôt le
matin et puis voilà quoi voilà c'est ça
un peu de randonnée ça peut être à pied
ça peut être un canoë kayak par exemple
quand je suis sur des étangs notamment
sur les étangs de saint martin où
d'autres et on prélève de l'eau donc je
travaille souvent avec des
collaborateurs
on peut lève de l'eau on est mon analyse
si j'ai senti un dodo pour par exemple
évaluer le taux de pollution qu'il ya
dans ces écosystèmes
on observe la faune la flore ont fait
des inventaires voilà tout ça c'est le
coeur de métier
donc ça peut être soit des études très
ponctuelles en un temps limité soit des
suivis sur des années comme par exemple
je peux donner il y a dix ans on étudiés
l'impact du cyclone dean sur la mangrove
de génie pas donc là c'était tout un
consortium de scientifiques et de
technique
ça vous travaillez pour d'aidé des
pouvoirs publics nationaux ou locaux
enfin je sais pas moi vous êtes
partenaires de l'eau des oeufs par
exemple mal à l'otv oui voilà mal à
l'odieuse sont vos partenaires officiels
alors l'office de l'eau arrivait aussi
peut-être oui oui pierre privé
absolument l'office de l'eau évidemment
puisque l'office de l'eau elle elle
travaille c'est son coeur de métier de
travailler sur le suivi des rivières de
faire de la sensibilisation au c'est du
prêt auprès du grand public est donc
évidemment c'est un partenaire très
privilégiée mais ça peut être aussi le
parc ça peut être aussi l'état là des
halles
ça peut être aussi des suivis dans le
cadre de directive cadre européenne
et puis je travaille en collaboration
avec d'autres bureaux d'études en partie
un partenariat ou d'autres consultants
privés
voilà c'est un c'est un mélange qui
dépend en fait de la mission de la
question qui est posée
voilà alors avec la menace qui pèse sur
l'environnement l'écologie évidemment
c'est on se rencontre c'est un métier
évidemment qui est certainement utile et
qui sait en le décrivant ainsi peut-être
qu'on a suscité quelques vocations chez
ce jeune martiniquaise où on marque ni
quand deux jeunes personnes vivent ici
allez on en vient à cette convention de
ramsar donc dont on fait précisément
aujourd'hui 2 février 2021
les cinquante ans une convention pour la
conservation mais pas seulement et
l'utilisation durable des zones humides
absolument comment ça s'applique ici par
exemple alors eh ben c'est vrai que
cette convention ramsar
elle concerne 171 pays c'est important
de recadrer un peu
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est un
traité jour international à cet
international et ça représente près de
2500 sites un petit peu moins de 2500
sites à travers le monde
et si je résume en france on en a 50 est
ici en martinique on a la chance d'avoir
un site ramsar qui est l'étang des
salines et l'étain des salines pourquoi
il a été choisi pour représenter pour
être labellisée ramsar c'est parce que
d'abord il ya une diversité d'habitats
justement mangrove vasières cordon
sableux et tend à nous tout ça ça fait
des compartiments différents dans
lesquels peuvent se développer
diversité très importante d'une part
d'autre part il a un patrimoine
historique très important c'était un
étang dans lequel on prélevait le sel
donc jusqu à peu près la seconde guerre
mondiale donc une valeur patrimoniale
troisièmement c'est un étang qui est
complètement représentatif d'écosystèmes
caribéen les étangs on en trouve comme
ça à saint martin on en trouve dans
d'autres il est donc c'est pour ça que
c'était intéressant de le mettre en
avant alors il est labellisé depuis 2008
et c'est le conservatoire du littoral
qui sont d'ailleurs des partenaires que
j'ai pas citer tout à l'heure mais
effectivement qu'ils sont propriétaires
de cet étang aient une partie aussi du
littoral était le nfc
alors cet étang des salines de kia qui
est labellisé ramsar comme vous le dites
en 2021 où en est on est ce qu'il ya une
menace particulière et orbi s'en
préoccuper vraiment voilà il fait c'est
comme la plupart des zones humides alors
celui-là est assez bien protégé au
niveau du foncier donc il n'a il ne
craint pas on va dire le grignotage
comme d'autres zones humides d'arrière
manque de le voter demain
voilà c'est une zone qui est quand même
assez pour l'accueil qui est fixée en
revanche il ya une pression avec des
pollutions diffuses qu'on ne voit pas
forcément écoulement par exemple des
champs agricoles qui sont tout autour
sur les bassins versants
on a eu aussi on sait que cette zone à a
été utilisé dans le temps pour déverser
des déchets donc il ya des traces encore
de polluants qui sont présents dans le
site donc ça va être de l'ordre de la
pollution plus + diffuse dans l'eau les
polluants chimiques qui se voit
peut-être même voir forcément comme ça à
vue d'oeil
mais qu'il faut aller chercher analyse
et là précisément
donc on a parlé de l'étang des salines
vous avez fait aussi beaucoup de
d'études inde analyse d'autres zones
humides autres milieux aquatiques en
martinique 1 donc notamment parlé du
littoral bon et on pense aux mangroves
violemment mais il ya les rivières
d'autres petits étangs et puis alors
précisément dit mais alors c'est ça la
martinique elle a vraiment cette chance
d'avoir un territoire très très variés
magnifique c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs
que j'ai collé ici alors que j'étais
venu pour très peu de temps mais quelle
quelle beauté de diversité de paysages
elle compte pas moins de deux mille deux
cent soixante seize zones humides c'est
énorme ça représente 2,5 du 2 5 % du
territoire et elles sont variées il ya
des mares les répits s'il veut donc les
répits s'il sait les moins connus c'est
les fourrés de bord de cours d'eau très
important parce que ça stabilise le
cours d'eau ça filtre l'eau ça permet
que l'eau soit épuré qu'elle retourne au
cycle de l'eau avec une qualité
meilleure et toutes ses zones humides
sont connectées entre elles et elles
nous sont alors là on a va avoir une
vision très centré sur l'humain mais
elles nous sont d'une 1/2 l'intérêt
capital pourquoi parce que sans eau
numide on déstabilise le cycle de l'eau
en vendée va lui en fait la qualité de
l'eau et donc de l'eau potable et en
plus de ça elles ont un rôle aussi de
régulation au niveau des inondations ce
sont des éponges quand il fait trop
c'est qu'elle re largue de l'eau
bref les zones humides à part le côté
par rapport à tout ce que vous dites
donc il faut là on parle davantage dans
un premier temps de préservation avant
même de penser à la mise en valeur la
valorisation ce que ce soit par exemple
concernant le développement du tourisme
effectivement ces utilitaires
c'est à dire que souvent je pense que
depuis des années on a considéré les
zones humides avec une lubie un peu
d'écolo qui regardent les libellules etc
certes c'est sympa de regarder les
libellules dans les zones humides mais
en fait elle a un rôle beaucoup plus
important de régulation
elles nous sont utiles il coûte cinq
fois moins cher de conserver une zone
humide que de compenser en fait la perte
de cette zone humide en faisant du
drainage ou des choses comme ça donc
c'est en ce sens qu'il faut qu'il faut
bien considérer que les zones humides ce
n'est pas juste un habitat pour la
biodiversité c'est bien d'autres choses
nous reste deux minutes d'entretien
mélanie rtement écologue le généraliste
spécialiste dans le domaine des milieux
aquatiques des zones humides on rappelle
aujourd'hui on fête les 50 ans de la
convention de ramsar justement pour la
conservation et l'utilisation durable
des zones humides sur l'étang des
salines le fait que ce soit je reviens
et puis on va terminer sur un peu les
priorités selon vous qu'il ya pour
l'usager mais aussi la protection de nos
milieux aquatiques mais le fait que
qu'il y ait une labellisation ramsar est
ce que ça implique des moyens
budgétaires ou technique supplémentaire
pour justement pouvoir d'abord protéger
et valoriser le site en question par
exemple étant des salines disons que le
fait d'être labellisé ramsar depuis 2009
ça donne la possibilité effectivement de
lever des fonds plus facilement puisque
c'est un affichage internationales
reconnues d'intérêt
donc c'est plus facile de défendre une
zone comme les salines qu'une petite
mare dans un coin que personne connaît
effectivement donc pour mobiliser des
fonds pour faire son suivi sa protection
et du cours répercute répercuter en fait
cette action sur l'ensemble des zones
humides c'est plus facile c'est plus
facile c'est pour ça que on peut être
fier d'avoir une zone humide labellisés
sur le territoire d'ailleurs pour
pouvoir parler des autres comme
aujourd'hui
voilà alors je précisément on y vient
pour pour conclure parce que nos milieux
aquatiques on était quand même
beaucoup misé à mal ces dernières années
bon évidemment on pense à la pollution
avec les pesticides un de toute nature
agricole chlordécone
bien sûr ça défraie la chronique depuis
depuis longtemps mais voilà et donc de
ce point de vue quelles sont les
priorités et puis est-ce qu'il ya encore
des moyens finalement supplémentaires
qu'il faudrait mettre dans cette action
écolo gique pour le coup il y a des des
pollutions effectivement préoccupantes
effectué alors une à laquelle on pense
pas c'est l'assainissement non collectif
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui va sortir de
nos maisons et qui normalement donc on
doit être aux normes avec des systèmes
de fausses voilà et le problème ici
comme c'est encore à résoudre
oui c'est un gros problème de pression
sur les milieux c'est même peut-être
même le premier problème de pression sur
les milieux aquatiques et des zones
humides que l'aude et l'office de l'eau
d'ailleurs prend à bras le corps un
puisqu'elle met en place des systèmes
d'études de suivi et étudie la
possibilité justement de pouvoir aider
les personnes à améliorer leurs systèmes
d'assainissement non collectif et l'état
aussi a fait une étude récemment à
laquelle j'ai participé pour repérer si
vous voulez sur le territoire quelles
sont les zones les plus à l'est les
zones les plus concernées les purées
corner par ce partage d'assainissement
donc là c'est tout le monde ça concerne
tout le monde et chacun tous toutes les
personnes qui ont une maison on va dire
et c'est 60% de la population en
martinique qui est à l'assainissement
non collectif doit se poser la question
de savoir
oui c'est ça le reste est un
assainissement collectif sur les 60 %
des à la population qui est un
assainissement collectif certains sont
aux normes d'autres pensent l'être et
chacun doit se poser la question de
savoir quel est mon impact avec ma
maison sur un fauteuil le milieu parce
que des territoires c'est ça parce que
les eaux usées qui ne sont pas
suffisamment filtré traités etc
à part justement cette cet
assainissement sa porte bien son nom bah
ça se déversent dans les rivières sur le
littoral etc et donc
évidemment ça impacte ses impacts merci
mélanie et retenant on aurait de quoi
parlait beaucoup plus longtemps mais bon
vous reviendrez peut-être ici ou dans
une autre émission en tout cas merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions donc à
l'occasion de ses 50 ans de la
convention de ramsar on parlait donc
écologie avec vous et colloques
généralistes merci bonne journée à 20